how do I know how do I know so quickly
that I'm going to get an oblique
asymptote yeah okay so let's introduce
some more language here again remember
we talked about the fact that language
isn't just learnt because let's make
things harder memorize right language is
powerful it helps you describe things
okay so can you see the powers that are
on these numerators and denominators
right the highest power that you see is
what we call the degree we distinguish
that from just saying the power because
for instance if I had x squared plus 2x
plus 1 right it's like when I say Oh
what's the power of the numerator answer
which which term do you want the power
is all different
so degree just means the highest power
so it's a quadratic right so what I'm
looking for is I'm trying to compare the
degree of the numerator versus the
degree of the denominator okay okay now
when you compare these things that will
tell you whether you have a horizontal
or oblique asymptote for something else
as well see in a second okay so have a
look at this guy
have a look at this guy this has a
horizontal asymptote there he is okay
and the reason why it has a horizontal
asymptote is because this tiny on the
bottom is growing and growing and the
numerator is just staying put right so
therefore the whole thing gets smaller
and smaller and smaller and smaller and
that's why I purchase 0 so that makes
sense ok what if I gave you a slightly
different one what if I gave you
something like this ok now what's this
going to be doing again we want to
investigate this idea what's happening
as X approaches very very extreme values
on opposite ends ok if for instance I
put in a value like a thousands in here
because I can compute a thousand what's
gonna happen to this
it's gonna be 999 in the top and it'll
be a thousand and one on the bottom
right 999 over a thousand and one what
if I put in a million if I put me in a
million then it's going to be 999,999
over a million and one right these
numbers right they are getting closer
and closer and closer to a particular
number namely one right by the way are
they above or below one it just below up
just below so these guys are approaching
one from below okay from below okay now
if I put a negative values like instead
of positive a thousand I put negative a
thousand okay you're going to get well
let's just try one out shall we
if I put in minus a thousand here I'm
gonna get minus a thousand and one / -
999 if I put in what okay so I've got
signs going like this they cancel so I'm
still approaching one on time but I'm
approaching one from above okay pause
what kind of asymptote is this its
horizontal it's just it's just a bit
higher just to be higher that's all okay
why is it that I get a horizontal
asymptote and the answer is when I
compare the degree of the numerator and
the degree of the denominator they are
equal that's exactly right so they're
both they're both growing like picture
these guys they're both growing but
they're growing at much the same rate
like they're this they're going to sort
of cancel each other out as they both
work just why are you approach a number
does that make sense okay just for kicks
what if I change this to it too
the degrees are still matching aren't
they
okay but what's gonna happen is instead
of 999 it's gonna be 2,000 - 1099 right
and he it'll be what so it's still going
to be approaching number but it'll be
approaching 2 instead of 1 make sense
yes yep
very good good excellent that's a great
question
why is it but here the degrees are
different and I get a horizontal
asymptote here the degrees are the same
but I get a horizontal asymptote okay in
order to get a number out of this okay
essentially what we want is for that
ratio between them to be approaching
just a number that's what we want right
like zero or one or two right and the
two ways you can get that off if the
denominator here right has a bigger
degree it will outstrip whatever the
numerators does that make sense
okay so let's let's change this up again
let's suppose I gave you okay now again
that numerators that's gonna grow isn't
it as X approaches infinity but guess
what the denominators gonna do it's
gonna grow so much faster
like vastly faster okay so this thing is
going to approach just like this thing
it's gonna press zero okay cuz no matter
how big that numerator gets and it will
get maybe it will approach positive
infinity
okay the denominator will approach
positive infinity faster does that make
sense okay so therefore if the degree of
the numerator is less than or equal to
the degree of the denominator okay that
will give you a horizontal asymptote
okay will give you a horizontal
asymptote because you've gotta approach
some kind of number now once you see
that inequality there's an obvious
counter case of that which sort of jumps
out at you right if the degree of the
numerator is not less than or not equal
to the degree of the denominator then
what is it it's it's it's it's bigger
isn't it if the degree of the numerator
is greater than the degree of the
denominator okay so now let's take
these guys and if I say how about this
hmm actually I didn't even need to write
that down because we already have one of
these thank you see this here the degree
of the numerator is bigger than the
degree of the denominator okay as you
put in big numbers right like a hundred
or a thousand or a million you end up
with some troubles right let's just be
really really approximate right when
this is a really big number when x is a
really big number how important is that
one answer insignificant right when
you're standing next to a million or a
billion or a trillion that one almost
might as well not be there okay so
essentially what you're getting is kind
of like this right does that make sense
x squared over X so therefore as you
approach really big numbers
you're basically approaching X aren't
you okay because for instance let's just
try let's just try test x equals a
thousand right I'm going to get a
million and one over a thousand right
which is roughly equal to a thousand is
it not and if I put in like larger and
larger numbers I'm always going to get x
squared roughly on the top and I'm going
to get exactly X on the bottom so x
squared on X that will give me X there's
another way you can see this remember
you told me right at the beginning over
here and this is a crucial result
whatever X right it's going to become
insignificant
as X approaches positive or negative
nor it so the very first way I gave you
this graph write this function
there's whatever X so what happens to
that part of it as X approaches negative
infinity answer it becomes zero that guy
goes to zero so all you get left with is
this guy
yeah so therefore therefore now my
asymptote is not going to be horizontal
it's going to be oblique you get an
oblique asymptote and the week essence
what you get is y equals x y equals x so
let's draw this guy in y